[Musique]
oui pardon madame excusez moi est ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre l'avortement
oh moi je suis suis jeune fille est en
jeu mais il est question de changer la
loi est égale écouter on ne pas tuer un
quelqu'un et c'est tout on emmène toi on
ne tue pas vous pensez que c'est un
crime d'avoir exactement mais aussi
parce que le monde n'a pas trop il a
peut être trop laisser disparaître il ya
une loi il ya une loi est l'un des 19
centrales et de melin jeannin et ogg
je suis pour parce que j'en ai eu
beaucoup et puis ça suffit maintenant je
suis fatigué des gosses si vous aviez pu
avorter ce que vous auriez fait ainsi je
les fais déjà c'est pas que je les fais
est ce que vous n'avez plus plusieurs
fois et je suis bien contente parce que
trop de gosse comme ça c'est pas combien
d'enfants avez vous en maintenant j'en
ai cinq mais je n'avais 8
mais est ce que vous ne pensez pas que
vous avez risqué votre vie en avortant
de mauvaises conditions
quand on est dans ces moments là où on
pense pas à rire on est on est content
d'être soulagé mais y en a que ça plaît
pas par exemple mon voisin et la digue
os les bien content d'abord comment ça
se fait alors tant qu'à faire le faire
légalement que le faire en cachette
je vais vous dire qu'on castres les
hommes c'est beaucoup mieux vernon la
castration exactement madame pour la
castration
oui parfaitement y a pas d'enfant on y
tue pas comme ça oui on est tu pas vous
prenez des filles 40 il c'est vrai vous
n'êtes pas l'avortement oui certainement
pourquoi madame parce qu' on est déjà
bien semoun sur la terre alors mettre
des petits enfants malheureux monde vaut
mieux les laisser où ils sont ne pensez
pas qu'il vaudrait mieux diffuser la
contraception à salins n'empêche
s'il l'on sait par plaisir que l'on n'y
a pas de raison qu'elle va le supprimer
après elles ont pris du plaisir pour la
voir alors pourquoi cavale le supprimer
c'est quand même elles vivent près tout
si ça vous arrive vous resteriez je le
garderais tu prends des risques
après tout c'est un enfant malgré tout
seul ils l'ont eue il s'en contente de
l'avoir ils ont pris du plaisir en ayant
au moins sont celles qui veulent se
faire avorter
vous pensez que le plaisir se peut
exactement moi je trouve que
l'avortement livrent à des problèmes
dans le sud est pas sous certaines
conditions
d'accord surveillance médicale par
exemple et parce que moi j'estime que si
y'avait l'avortement libre il n'y aurait
pas tant de femmes qui désirent pas
d'enfants qui sont obligés de l'avoir
mais moi ça me choque je l'aimais
difficilement ce coffret vous êtes pour
un changement de la loire oui dans quel
sens dans le sens de la vente mon livre
remboursés par la sécurité sociale par
la sécurité sociale est réglementé ou
non réglementée c'était quelle façon on
doit pas faire plusieurs avortements à
mon avis de saisies c'est déjà pas mal
s'il avait une vraie politique de la
contraception si par exemple on donnait
plus librement la pilule ce que vous
pensez pas durer moins d'avortements
2010 à devenir pilule on leur donnait
plus automatiquement ils n'ont plus peur
serait peut-être mieux non ça vous savez
c'est difficile de difficile parce que
la pub d'un côté paris c'est pas
tellement beaux moments temps vous ai
pas mal alors vous savez vous préférez
l'avortement à la pilule
moi je pourrais passer palmans je
préférais l'appartement pendant une
jeune fille de 16 ans et 17 ans est
enceinte est ce qu'elle pourrait se
faire avorter ce genre oh non parce
qu'après ça va être
on ne s'en sort plus penser qu'il y
aurait des aspects ce sera la porte
ouvert portes ouvertes à quoi pas à tous
les abus à tous on se dire ah bon on
peut y aller tranquillement puisqu'on
aura toujours la prendre les secours
chaque famille a un problème personne ne
le dira mais chaque famille a un
problème sayah potter sachez pour
l'avortement sayah pour l'histoire ça
c'est à quel genre de problème faites
vous allusion problème familial problème
mental je connais beaucoup de ménages
dont amène à chaud - dont la femme est
débile mental à deux gosses en un
troisième le mari alcoolique selon vous
madame la loi sur l'avortement doit elle
changer en france
je ne pense pas vous êtes donc contre
l'avortement légalisé
pourquoi mois déjà par mon travail
et puis ma question à moi moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à grandir et je conçois
mal qu'une femme lui rejette quand elle
l'a toutes les femmes ne sont pas dans
votre cas nous bien sûr il y en a quand
sept huit enfants qui aiment tellement
pas désiré oui la da cunha dit ya
d'énormes enfin ce qu'il ya moi je pense
qu'il faudrait par exemple quand ça
arrive à une jeune personne une jeune
fille dont qu'elle puisse aller quelque
part prendre les conseils qu'elle n'ait
pas peur de le dire que bien souvent
quand elles font des bêtises
après ils ont peur de nous communiquer
sarr aussi bien aux parents il faut
aller parents qui ne sont pas allés
parler des enfants et encore des jeunes
filles alors rappelle qu' ils sont au
courant de rien vous avez défi et une
fille
quel âge at-elle 9 ans et est ce que
vous lui donnerez la pilule quand elle
rend casse
1 je suis contre contre la piraterie
je suis content pour la pilule pour les
jeunes parce que c'est vraiment l'heure
donné quartier libre
j'aimerais mieux lui faire confiance
lui dire tout ce qu'elle peut ce qu'elle
peut récolter mais vraiment lui faire
confiance
et si votre fille alors à l'âge de 15 16
ans tombée enceinte jusqu'à n'aurait pas
de pilules et vous êtes contre
l'avortement que feriez vous à je crois
je m'ennuie élever son enfant
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
changer la loi
oui dans quel sens large here puis
ultime s'ils veulent pas d'enfant et
s'ils veulent se faire avorter ce
montant avec un homme bisetto il est
joli et plus - écoutez moi ça fait 18
ans que je suis marié je prends pas la
pilule et j'ai qu'un enfant jamar et
qu'il travaille très bien vous êtes
catholique madame or n'ont pas tellement
faim je vais à l'église quand même
l'avortement pour ou contre m
[Musique]
j'imagine que vous n'avez jamais être
que vous êtes pour ou contre que les
autres à bord qui compte les contres
pourquoi je la mets les enfants ah bah
si j'aime ça
oui mais quand la mère ne veut pas de
l'enfant vous pensez qu'elle n'est pas
libre de décider s'il veut ou non de
neuf chez elle quant à lui alors oui je
serais plutôt pour l'avortement pour des
personnes qui sans qu'ils peuvent pour
faire de l'enfant
je vous ai dit que je suis important
pourquoi eh bien je faisais du pouvoir
raison il ya des faits d il ya des fois
des pauvres des personnes des jeunes
filles par exemple ils ont des
difficultés ou pour l'élever ou pour la
famille c'est normal qu on est
chrétienne et bien
on est but de ces choses vous trouvez
finalement que je ne devrais pas parler
de ces choses là bas n'ont retrouvé que
j'ai tort de poser le problème pour
connaissiez pensez y autour de bons à
rien dans les jeunes ceux qui se sentent
justement le plus concerné ce sont les
jeunes dont beaucoup ne vote pas il ya
comme des organismes qui me font au vu
de tout le monde d'ailleurs
mais sans avoir aucun ennui moi j'ai vu
la mnef avions bon et d'ailleurs c'est
dans les journaux il ya d'autres
viennent d'autres organismes du genre il
ya le lac
il fait également dans de très bonnes
conditions autant ces conditions là
d'accord mais qu'on interdise le fer
vont les faiseuses d'anges c'est bien
connu
l'aiguillé à tricoter c'est quand même
portel - yannick si la loi et pour ça
nous décider je trouve c'est pas au
gouvernement décidé qu'on a pris ses
responsabilités en faisant donc je
trouve ces pots gouvernement de décider
si on doit être ça doit le faire ou pas
c'est à nous mêmes tout le monde peut
apporter à condition d'avoir une
certaine somme d'argent
si c'est toi passe passe à l'elysée
avortement continueront si ça devait
exister enfin c'est vraiment ça va être
établi enfin pour mon cas personnel je
me serais peut-être quand marié et je
serais peut-être pas te ment divorce et
tout le monde on partait comme il
l'entend et comme ça vous plaît mais
enfin que maintenant il ya d'autres
possibilités que l'avortement c'est des
gens étaient peut-être plus informés
personnellement pas catholique
m'enfin toute façon je pense pas que ce
soit non plus le problème des
catholiques raison que des curés ou les
élèves de les signer point de vue des
appartements alors que c'est les mecs
n'ont absolument rien à voir avec la
sexualité autre chose c'est un problème
personnel
un problème féminin déjà à et je ne vois
pas pourquoi des gens qui sont des
hommes un désinfectant pour le mlf des
gens qui sont des hommes qui ont 50 ans
qui sont rangés tous les problèmes même
des femmes j'en ai vu la télévision un
dernier débat 1 qui ont 50 ans donc qui
sont dégagées tout problème qui vont
décider problème de jeune fille ou john
pham et je crois que c'est aux jeunes
filles aux jeunes femmes de décider si
elle va porter ou non ou si elles ont le
droit de garder leurs enfants si elle
désire profondément et il doit être mis
à leur disposition le moyen d' aides
apportées comme elles le veulent
[Musique]